my coach he was really proud of that
moment because we only ever had one
because he saw me at my lowest one time
and then saw me what was your still
trying to fight one time i only have a
knockout loss and he said i was still
trying to fight like i got up she's
still trying to fight me
so he knew
this guy when you know when that when
the going gets tough
he'll rise so that fight was important
for him to see because when it came to
that point that fifth round before the
fifth round he's he came to he came on
this side and he said you know this is
what we've done we've been here before
we've been here before wow and then i
turned around and i see calvin just
there kelvin's doing this
yep no he looked like the devil i call
it diablo yeah and i was like
you're not going to beat me
i'm prepared to die you've you said that
too right now did it yeah i didn't read
it i said it i said it out loud but you
read it you can read my letter i said it
i saw you say something yes i said it
you're not going to beat me i'm prepared
to
[Music]
i die in my pocket pull out the grenade